want to say hello and good evening when
I'm not just too mayor Buda judge well
it's not just us is Damita no combat
role Caballero many of your colleagues
on stage support free college you do not
why not
sure so college affordability is
personal for us Jocelyn and I have six
figures student debt
I believe in reducing student debt it's
logical to me that if you can refinance
your house you ought to be able to
refinance your student debt I also
believe in free college for low and
middle income students for whom cost
could be a barrier I just don't believe
it makes sense to ask working-class
families to subsidize even the children
of billionaires I think the children of
the wealthiest Americans can pay at
least a little bit of tuition and while
I want to ition cost to go down I don't
think we can buy down every last penny
for them now there's something else that
doesn't get talked about in the college
affordability debate yes it needs to be
more affordable in this country to go to
college it also needs to be more
affordable in this country to not go to
college you should be able to live well
afford rent be generous to your church
literally whether you went to college or
not that's one of many reasons we need
to raise the minimum wage to at least
$15 now